Uh so with without any further delay,
let's round out our day with Sophia
Polet and Joseph from HSBC.
Sophia is the product owner of graphs at
HSBC. I had a lovely chat right right
before we started.
She has over a decade of experience in
finance and banking data management.
Joseph is an analyst and a graph geeks
member. I will say. And with a focus on
leveraging knowledge graphs and AI to
develop innovative solutions in the
finance sector. Today they're going to
share how HSBC is using knowledge graphs
to streamline data governance and
enhance regulatory compliance. So let's
give a welcome to Sophia and Joseph.
Thank you for joining us.
>> [applause]
>> Right.
Thank you Amy and thank you
Connected Data London for having us
here. It's our first time here and I was
just talking with Amy. I just feel so
energized. It feels like you know it's a
place where we belong talking to all
graph
enthusiasts who share the same craziness
as us because it's not easy to find
people who get graph understand graph.
So it's really a uh
exciting experience to be here. Learned
a lot yesterday and we hope to spend
more time and come again. And with that
said, a little introduction about
myself. I'm Sophia. Um I've been with
the organization HSBC in specific for
over six years to seven years now.
Before that I was with another mutual
fund company.
All my experience I've been in the data
management space. But my introduction to
graph came in HSBC. And today we'll be
talking about what we've actually done
in HSBC.
One one the use case. It's not the only
use case in our bank. It's one of the
use case where we use graph. And
I'll let my colleague introduce himself.
>> Hi, good afternoon everyone. I'm Joseph.
I'm representing the HSBC bank.
I've been in this space for almost 2
years right now and very grateful to be
part of the graph data community. So,
today we're going to explain to you how
HSBC uses graphs to leverage
how HSBC leverage knowledge graph for
its regulatory compliance commitments.
So, let's see how it's done.
>> And before we get into the topic, a
little bit about what our organization
is. You might have seen HSBC around
while you were you know, you must be
commuting here in London.
And
the main big three services that
So, we are a bank. The three main
services that we offer is wealth and
private banking, commercial banking,
global banking and markets. And across
all these three services, we cover more
than 41 million customers across the
globe. And this is an offering that's
more than 60 markets. And this is
something
our bank has been doing for over 150
years.
So, you can imagine the scale of data
and the complexity of landscape across
different markets and the
scale of regulations as well. I think in
the morning one of in the one of the
presentation
the more global bank you are, the more
regulators regulations you're going to
be bound by. And that's the scenario
with us.
And our bank has um
devised some strategies that will
actually help us effectively manage our
data. So, there are four core
strategies, but one of the main core
strategies based on which we will
introduce the graph is what we call
digitize at scale.
Which I think most of the organizations
would have done in the past Uh, we were
years technology or databases were not
necessarily available then. So, our
journey started with moving our data
from our ledger books, record books into
our inventories. And at that point in
time,
all the data was, yes, put into
inventories, but everything was done in
silos. It was all done in all over the
place. Some into RDBMS base, some no
sequel, some all sorts of inventories
were used, and it was all over the
place.
And over a period of time, as and when
we started accumulating data,
it also started raising some problems
and challenges. Of course, one of the
biggest challenges is siloed.
And also, why that was a problem is we
being audited by multiple regulations.
Whenever a regulator asks for something
or evidence, some information,
we just need to scurry around to find
where's the right data, which is the
right source, because there are also
copies of data across the bank. Because
people just go to the nearest source and
get the information, not necessarily the
right place to do it. But people have
done that, and sometimes that's led to
incorrect representation reporting as
well.
And
you can see, using this kind of setup,
it's very difficult to travel the maze
of
looking at our reporting data, finance
data, or any compliance data that's
required. It's very difficult for us to
traverse across the organization.
And this is was the main challenge
point. And my colleague will talk about
how did we try to address it.
>> So, yeah, I'm going to tell you a story
about
losing an umbrella, basically. So,
imagine that it's a very rainy windy
day. You go to the railway station, and
then you go to the cafe, get a cup of
coffee, you met your colleagues, you
have a good chat with them, and you
spend, let's say, 10 minutes in the
station. And on the way, you have
misplaced your umbrella somewhere. So,
you What do you do? You go back to the
cafe and check with the staff. You check
with the staff at the railway station.
And there wasn't any cameras around. So,
no one kept a log of what the other
person was doing, but someone saw that
you misplaced your umbrella someplace,
but you didn't know who that person was.
So, that data was siloed in the person's
mind. And you never knew it.
The data wasn't linked. So, what do you
do? You end up buying a new umbrella.
Now, how does this relate to a finance
scenario?
So,
regulators come and ask for data
traceability, and different
organizations within the bank will
document data based on their own
understanding. For example, finance side
would document data based on their
understanding. The wealth management
part would do based on their
understanding. And all of these data
will be in different silos, different
repositories, different data lakes. And
regulator comes back and asks you, "How
does your wealth management data relate
to your retail customers?" Which is very
logical question. But, because you have
documented things in completely
different manner,
uh no one will be able to link these
data together. So, what is the solution?
Introducing knowledge graphs.
Knowledge graphs is an amalgamation of
four things.
First is knowledge. So, again I'll take
a finance example. So, a bank will have
retail customers, commercial customers,
and customers would own things like
stocks, bonds, mutual funds, etc. So,
these are known facts. So, this
constitutes knowledge.
And the second thing that uh builds up a
knowledge graph is basically semantic
graph. A semantic graph is basically uh
things and not strings. So, you can link
your customer to the stocks they own,
the mutual funds they own. These are And
this brings up a graph. Now, these These
are just data points linked to each
other.
Now, an ontology is like a map or or it
governs our semantic graph. So, an
ontology consists of broadly two things,
classes and properties.
So, as I said, we have
uh
customers that are commercial in nature
or retail in nature. These can be
grouped into a common instance called uh
clients or customers. And
products like not products, assets like
uh let's say stocks, bonds, etc. can be
grouped to to a class called assets.
And
having an ontology uh
on on top of a knowledge graph will give
us the power of reasoning. You can infer
new facts, which would uh
help us uh to
uh interpret logic defined by data rules
uh of structure to derive new knowledge.
And knowledge graph gives us standards.
So, here we are going to talk about
audio standards mainly. So, as you know,
the internet is uh
huge network of documents that are
linked to each other through URLs. And
what RDF says your data points should be
linked to each other through unique
identifier.
And OWL is the uh is called the web
ontology language, which uh basically
says says how your data should be
governed, how your data should be uh
classified, and how data should be
linked to each other. And SPARQL is a
language, as you all know,
which can be leveraged to uh query RDF
graphs.
And what are the key benefits of having
such standards? You can connect your
data from different sources very
seamlessly,
and which ensures that you have
consistency across your data, which
helps you to scale your data to
uh scale your data without any
redesigning, and gives you the power of
advanced analytics.
>> And uh
just before I get into the topic, just
to tell us tell uh how did our journey
start? And as I mentioned, it started in
the data management world. So, we
started back in 2018.
Um and back then, of course, graph
wasn't something that everybody
understood or understood the value of.
So, we started uh developing some
solution based on Pythonic uh
frameworks.
Uh we proved out some uh POCs saying,
"Yes, you get the value out of using uh
graphs." And in 2020, we uh scaled up to
try and use some open source. Again,
because whatever we had proved using our
POC was something that we had to scale.
And we were on the open source platform
for uh quite some time, for at least 3
years. And using this solution itself,
we were able to support quite a few
regulatory compliance requirements. And
beyond that, uh why because we were able
to prove that using this kind of uh
framework and technology helps us in
more faster, more proactive, and reduces
redundancies as well. We don't need to
reinvent the wheel all over again for
some other regulation again.
Um
There has also been an increase in
different kind of use case, even beyond
regulatory initiatives, which required
us to have more uh core strength. And uh
this year, we also further enhanced our
product to uh
enterprise solution, uh which I'll talk
about in a bit. And um as my colleague
mentioned, right? Ontology is the
important part and is what drives the
graph. So, um
as everyone said, we, you know, what is
it that gives uh
graph its knowledge? Uh
in our organization, so we know what an
ontology is and, you know, why it's
important. So, what was the take at HSBC
without saying the O word? Um HSBC has
something uh which we call it as the
enterprise meta model. Now, this is the
model that no matter which part of the
organization that you sit in, they need
to adhere to this as part of a data
management capabilities. So, we cannot
say one part of the business will say
when I manage my data, this is what I'm
going to call it. Or when I manage my
data in different part, this is
something else. So, across the
organization,
um all all the businesses are going to
leverage the same metamodel. Uh this
helps us in actually seamlessly
identifying how our data is mastered
across the organization, where it's
persisted, and what it's called without
losing the uh
terminology. And um just the visual
representation, the underlying core is
our data, which is governed by the
HSBC's enterprise metamodel. And using
that is what we actually model our
ontology. So, it's not just what we
think the ontology should be or what we
think our data should join up. Uh we are
guided by what the enterprise metamodel
says, and the combination of all of
these three things is what um
comes up uh as a final knowledge graph.
>> So, for our use case, we've made a very
sample ontology using our light formula.
So, the image that you see on the
right-hand side uh is basically the old
representation of the ontology that you
see um on the left-hand side.
So, uh here we have multiple classes.
So, the top class says uh regulation. A
regulation can mean any regulation that
we have in the world, GDPR, BCBS 239,
anything. And every regulation mandates
a certain compliance requirement. And
HSBC internally has a data policy like
uh
multiple banks across the world, which
addresses uh
different compliance requirements.
And the data and the applications that
the group uses is in scope of the HSBC
data policy. And we have used a common
class called country that would uh link
our application data and the regulation.
So, here we are highlighting that we can
reuse assets to
uh uh
we can reuse assets to uh like build a
knowledge graph through an ontology.
Now, let's look into how
uh we can Now, now let's look into a
broader description of the same through
a data example.
>> So, we've looked at the
What it says
a high-level ontology for a use case. Um
let's take regulation BCBS 239. And one
of uh its mandate is uh how is a bank uh
how is the data governance around a risk
aggregation capabilities? That's what
the policy mandates. And internally in
our organization, uh we have policy
which let's say is called data lineage.
And data lineage is one of the policy
that addresses the higher requirement of
governance. And when we say lineage,
it's usually documented for in scope of
data points. So,
assuming let's take for example customer
data is what is in scope for what BCBS
is asking for. And uh as part of
documenting a lineage, we start with
where is this data stored in? Uh just
take an example of customer onboarding
system. And uh
we also know that this is an application
that is hosted in UK. That means the
data center of this app is actually
hosted in UK. And uh also, when we talk
about lineage, it's about how is this
data flowing across the organization?
Uh which says it's This is the same data
that's uh flowing from uh customer
onboarding system to another risk
exposure engine. Um one interface. And
this is UK customer uh um
So, we can also infer that because the
data is uh flowing from an upstream
application to a downstream, it's also
stored in the consuming application. And
we also know that the app where it was
consumed is hosted in France. And uh
this data that was flowing uh was
related to UK.
Um and uh this also uh brings into scope
the application. So, in scope, I think
yesterday we were just talking when we
say regulation, it's a very generic
relationship. We just say apps are in
scope, your data is in scope, and you
know, this regulation
applies to some country. So, in this
example, we're just taking this
regulation applies to France.
Now, let's take another regulation,
GDPR, which again
mandates many things, but two examples
it is trying to look for how is the data
being transferred across geographies,
especially from a customer privacy
perspective, and what kind of customer
data we're actually storing. So, that's
the data retention ask. And for data
retention, our internal HSBC policy,
for for example's sake, is called data
privacy. And for data transfer, our
internal policy is lineage, which is the
same thing that addresses BCBS as well.
Now, because as part of BCBS, we've
already documented our information
for addressing GDPR ask of
there should not be any customer-related
information that is changing boundaries
or geographies. I can just look at the
data and analyze it. I don't need to go
around inventorying or documenting my
data all over again.
Because I know that customer data or UK
customer data is being sent from an app
which is hosted in UK to an app that's
hosted in France, I can easily identify
and
try to put the, you know, our required
controls or make a local instance of it
and do the necessary actions required.
But, this will immediately help GDPR to
understand what is our estate. We can
easily have an understanding of how our
estate is spanned. Similarly will be the
case for data privacy. Again, privacy or
or the higher ask is retention, which
says you need to know or we as a bank
need to tell
where are we storing customer data, how
long are we storing customer data, and
is it in the same geography or not.
So, similarly because
we know that what data is stored in
which applications, we can easily just
scan the material that's already there
and just
produce an output saying where actually
I'm not compliant or I need to do
something about
about my data. So, in this example, uh
what what we try to explain is even
though the two different regulations
uh
we were able to
we were able to reduce duplication of
efforts and we were able to leverage
what was already done to address BCBS
for our GDPR use case as well. And GDPR
is something again, you know, it for
example sake it applies to France and UK
both. Um so, this is how we were able to
leverage our graph
internally where when we're documenting
or inventing information, this are just
two examples of two regulations, but
there are a lot more regulations that we
were able to
just read the data and
provide outputs for it.
>> So, as you've seen in the previous
example, BCBS is a regulation that
basically asks for risk
aggregation capabilities of a bank and
GDPR is something that is completely
different that that talks about customer
privacy customer data privacy and how
data is transferred across geographies.
But at the core, these two
there are a lot of overlaps between
these two regulations that is having a
good governance framework and to have
good data lineage.
So, through a knowledge graph, we didn't
reinvent the wheel.
The work that was done for a particular
regulation could be reused
for the other regulation.
>> And
this was our tech stack. So, when I
mentioned this year we had to upscale to
enterprise solution. So, at the
core of our
at the core of our application,
we use an RDF based Altier Graph Studio,
which was formerly Anzo by Cambridge
Semantics. And we use Protege for our
ontology management and YFiles, which
you would have already seen here for our
visualization because, of course, our
use case is lineage, so it's very
important for users to actually
understand what data is uh flowing
across which boundaries. So, this is our
current tech stack that we're using for
our use case.
>> Yeah, so what is the future of knowledge
graph? We can reduce cost to a larger
scale by having a good ontology and
connecting data across silos. And that
would really improve the efficiency of
the different processes that your
organization or business handles.
>> Um and I think just in continuation,
also in conclusion,
um we as an organization, we very much
believe in trying to reuse and not
necessarily,
you know,
trying to get new tools into our bank.
As far as possible, we want to reduce
any redundancies, reuse what's
available. And by having this graph
platform, we're able to support a lot of
regulations in
without having to duplicate any efforts.
And it's also helping us uh scale across
different businesses across the bank,
not just in one area of the bank, but
across the bank we're able to do it. And
there's a lot more flexibility with the
data, which is allowing us to have
proactive compliance. Uh once all, you
know, it's already in organization where
across the bank, irrespective of what
the regulation is asking for,
all the business in the bank need to
adhere to the internal HSBC policies.
And one
once the data that is required for these
policies is inventoried, no matter what
a regulator is asking for from the data
perspective, we will always already have
it and it's just about pulling the data
and just responding to their queries.
So, having this kind of platform is
going to help us reduce cost. We don't
need to come up with
siloed inventories all over the place to
address one regulation and some other
regulation. Um overall, high efficiency,
scalability, and it gives us proactive
compliance.
And
that's it for me. Thank you.
>> Awesome. Thank you.